Nik I want you to do something for me I
want to hypnotize you hypnotize me is
not gonna make a difference it's been
very useful in the past and it might set
our minds at ease we might find out what
really happened nikka I don't want to
have to send you back to lock more
hypnosis helps you accept the truth you
know are you afraid of the truth dr. Foy
it's true
he's a lie what have you done to
yourself now no it was him Claire why
don't you come with us know how it was
it was him
[Music]
[Applause]
just relax so what doesn't mean Andy I
just want to be able to protect myself
from what exactly you googled me yeah I
did you have a very dark past yeah
so why didn't you tell me because I
liked you I didn't want to scare you
away I was six my babysitter was
murdered along with my teacher and my
caseworker and 37 other people over the
years I'm aware of how they never caught
him put it this way justice was done
wait play with this
[Music]
[Music]
again I said she was paralyzed
she is the juice see from the waist down
she's a pin cushion all right that's
enough
I can still see him
in my nightmares his twisted face that
horrible laugh glint off his blade
screams of his victim I was six my
babysitter was murdered and they never
caught him justice was done wanna play
[Music]
okay the murders reveal Chucky liver was
that's right he was a fantasy notion are
you feeling better now I don't blame you
for being afraid I was very ill Chucky
told me he's coming for you it's
important that we all explore it
together as a group I think I have
something that might help
whoa all right I'm Chucky wanna play
first I'll kill each and every one of
you the most horrible ways you can
imagine and then he'll kill me too
are you afraid of the truth
terrified you should be too night-night
and they call me sick wait a minute
there's two of them
atchoo classic never goes out of style
[Music]